hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk a little bit about grammar by
the way you notice i don't have my
glasses on i had
this eye
operated on so i can see so if i look in
the at the screen now if i close my bad
eye i can see very very clearly if i
close this eye it's a blur
eventually i'll have the other eye done
and then i'll see you know far away i'll
still need glasses for reading but
that's great
um grammar the importance of grammar
and how we should deal with grammar you
know there's this constant debate
some people say grammar is a waste of
time other people say that you have to
first learn the basics
and it's a theme that i've dealt with
before but i thought i would go into it
again
very quickly on the subject of videos in
different languages
we want to take our time doing them
because we want to develop
uh subtitles in english
but i got the list here frenchmen french
republic
you know it's hard to switch
france
um
i don't think i'll be able to handle
polish yet
and uh
vulvalar portuguese post
in portuguese anyway just to say that
i'll be going through those but i want
to wait until we're able to
to provide
subtitles um grammar
big debate on our forum at link
my view is this i think traditional
language instruction places far too much
emphasis on grammar
and it does it the wrong way it
introduces complicated explanations
complicated rules
and then a bunch of exercises where
you're
forced to try to
practice what you've just presumably
learned trouble is you don't learn it
because many of these correct usage
patterns take a while to assimilate and
therefore
i feel that rather than having even like
most books that you buy
language books are going to have 70
percent
grammar explanations exercises and a
small amount of text i think you should
have far more text interesting text with
the vocabulary lists and and some focus
on the basic patterns that show up in
this text and then they should be
introduced again in subsequent lessons
here again is this pattern that we've
seen before here's five more examples
here are two that show up in the lesson
so you're getting a chance to review the
basic patterns of worrying too much
about explanations you can have some
explanations
and without the drills and without the
exercises and focus mostly on
content and the reason is this a
language that you have had lots of
exposure in that you've spoken a lot in
you start to sense instinctively
what is correct and what isn't correct
not only in so far as the grammar rule
endings or whatever but also in terms of
word usage and this is just a matter of
getting used to the language and when
you are used to the language you
naturally say it correctly if you are
relying on your
recollection of the rule you will always
doubt yourself even when you got it
right even when you have a sense of how
it's used correctly
uh you will doubt yourself you want to
look it up you want to check against the
rule and that's not really good for
developing fluency so
focus more on comprehension on
vocabulary on input on getting used to
language with a little bit of help
by way of review of of basic grammar
patterns uh so grammar has its place but
that's how i would go about it and so
and trying to keep these videos short
we can have more discussion on the
subject if there's interest bye for now